philippe teulier bonjour j'aurais onic
merci d'être ici au théâtre montansier
partager on va parler de vous
de quelqu'un qui n'est pas l'art qui
s'appelle émis de la roche qui votre
alter ego car vous êtes à tous les deux
un groupe qui s'appelle saint michel qui
va être présent sur cette même scène le
31 janvier donc au théâtre montansier à
20h30
voilà la raison de notre rencontre et
donc moi j'aimerais en savoir plus sur
vous vous
ou votre groupe votre histoire déjà ce
nom saint michel alors ce que j'ai
oublié de dire c'est que vous êtes
versaillais voilà emile parisien
ouais voilà non mais vous vous êtes
versailles et vous travaillez à
versailles aussi comme on le verra plus
tard et je vivais et vous virer à
versailles voilà donc racault témoin ce
groupe saint-michel d'où vient ce nom
alors question tout le monde vous pose
alors le nom vient d'une envie d'avoir
quelque chose de français d'accord
on est conscient qu'on est un petit peu
absorbé par la culture anglo saxonne
déjà on chante en anglais on aime
beaucoup d'artistes d'outre-manche outre
atlantique et du coup on voulait trouver
quelque chose qui défendent un peu une
idée à la française donc on a commencé à
sortir des vieux bouquins d'histoire et
ont cherché dans les noms de personnages
chevalier de châteaufort de trucs du
genre c'était votre imaginaire
qu'est-ce qui vous voilez rêvé enfant
ouais absolument ou chercher des mots
qui sonnent assez assez français parfois
avec des trucs pas marché du tout du
coup on n'a pas laissé tomber
on pensait la gastronomie mais c'est un
peu trop gastrique
oui on a laissé tomber et on est tombé
sur saint michel des corps il n'y a qu'
on a fait deux trois petites recherches
et
et on a trouvé ça super et alors dites
moi vous avez démarré tous les deux il
ya combien de temps on a démarré en 2012
ah oui ces raisons je pense que le
premier petite sortie c'était un ep oui
qui s'appelait eyes of japan jvc veut
dire quoi hein p salaires 1/2 album six
chansons ouais cas entre quatre et six
chansons d'accord ok donc ça ce temps le
chaman c'était le titre d'une chanson
qui est au centre de deux exactement
hockey et donc du coup la création du
groupe septet 2011
on a travaillé il préparé ce ep écrire
les premières chances d'accord et donc
vous avez sorti un album
ouais un premier album qui s'appelle
making inde climbing voilà celui-là la
pochette 33 tours faire l'amour une
escalade faire l'amour elle escalade en
même temps en même temps c'est possible
tout est dit qu avant après aussi on
fait ça vient d'une interview qu'on a
fait
oui qui était en anglais et on nous a
demandé les choses qu'on préférait faire
un monde c'était sait des choses j'ai
répondu ça les camps s'est dit ça ferait
un bon final c'est mon vélo ça donc au
fait ça ces sorties vous m'avez dit en
octobre 2000 octobre 2013 voilà donc en
fait c'est ce que j'imagine les morceaux
qu'on va entendre sur scène
oui en partie avec des nouveautés et à
les nouveautés qui seront dans le
prochain album j'imagine qui est prévu
pour quand ça je peux pas vous dire on
sait pas non et c'est bien parce que ça
nous laisse le temps de de faire le
travail d'écriture
les producteurs voudraient avoir une
date
oui non lus tinto voilà on ne lâchera
pas d'accord bon et alors
maintenant pour revenir plus
personnellement avoué à emilie
vous vous êtes musicien à la base pas du
tout comment ça s'est passé 7
moi je suis musicien mais autodidacte ce
que j'ai pas du tout fait d'école de
musique le conservatoire au genre de
choses d'accord je sais pas encore pas
lire les notes aujourd'hui oui
amy lui a fait le conservatoire hockey
est ce que vous jouez comme on la
caractérise votre musique comme on
l'appelle c'est de la technique mais
enfin après c'est toujours compliqué
parce que c'est les noms les groupes les
sous-groupes les sous appellation la
définition c'est de la pop électro
d'accord ok est ce que vous sentez une
filiation par rapport à auxon versailles
et oui voilà ça vous parle quand on vous
dit non
oui oui c'est le cas mais je pense
qu'après on peut aussi être influencé ou
ressembler à des groupes qui sont à
l'autre bout de la terre comme comme les
autres groupes versailles et l'ont été
oui voilà voilà
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être une
petite il ya un petit fil rouge avec les
différents artistes qui existent dans la
région
donc on pense à r on pense à félix voilà
à etienne 2 etienne de crécy alex gopher
alors etienne de crécy alex gopher
russes et des dj vraiment donc c'est un
un petit peu différent d'accord les
coiffeurs il ya travaillé de vous gêner
avec on a travaillé avec souffert mais
il a mixé l'album ok donc ça va vers ça
y est c'est un versailles et si
maintenant installé à paris d'accord
tout les versaillais ont quitté le
bateau basso vous ben moi je suis revenu
de pareilles voilà c'est ça et dites moi
alors comment vous travaillez tous les
deux vous jouez de vous jouer quand même
d'un instrument mal du tout et j'ai dû
je fais des claviers je fais de la
guitare chez la batterie et je fais le
show le genre et c'est vous qui chantez
et émile les milf et de la basse ouais
avec la ville et des claviers d'accord
et donc vos paroles sont en anglais est
ce que c'est pourquoi pourquoi parce que
on aime beaucoup la musique anglo
saxonne comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'est une grosse influence et du coup
pour nous c'était naturel de chanter en
anglais
d'accord c'est comme ça que vous
fonctionnez voilà je vais peut-être
c'est de l'anglais ben ouais je me pose
pas la question et je le sens comme ça
ok mais qui sait peut-être que dans dix
ans chantait un album solo de chanson
française
oui je sais pas ouais mais à l'heure
actuelle je suis plus à l'aise avec la
langue anglaise à l'étranger justement
vous êtes allés jouer les festivals
comme hommage aux états unis on a
en italie on achemine à l'écart et ça
s'est passé c'était super c'est très
différent entre les états unis et la
chine
on a joué à new york dans dans un lieu
qui s'appelle le baron des cas qui est
donc un club un peu branché tout ça donc
là c'était un peu le oui qui étaient
attirés justement web est un défi wind
ouais ouais donc vous avez quelque part
je passais un public un peu un peu
acquis fin une des gens qui sont
attentifs à ce que je pense que là je
comprends qu'on a intérêt à ce courant
là parce que c'est un peu portés par la
vague de ceux d'avant garde oui
ouais moi je remercie du fond du coeur
tous les grands frères qui ont déjà
ouvert la voie et nous en vachement
inspiré je sais que moi même
personnellement je fais de la musique en
partie aussi grâce à un aliment donné
l'idée que c'était quelque chose de
possible c'est à dire qu'on pouvait
faire la musique dans sa vie ah oui
alors qu'à versailles sa ville
mon avis dans sa ville et dans sa vie
alors que ça il ya forcément évident
ouais est-ce que vous l'envisagez pas
petit bain je suis dans une famille
plutôt classique ou du cou
faire de la musique c'est bien mais le
soir et week-end plutôt donc jouer avec
les copains de samedi après midi au quai
tant qu'on continue ses études de
médecine à l'ingénieur il se trouve que
vous êtes d'ailleurs déjà des gens me le
dise encore oui j'ai fait une sorte de
traquenard comme ça mon père est
ingénieur j'ai dit je vais je vais faire
comme ingénieur accord je vais être
ingénieur du son bon bah comme ça ils
sont contents ouais aujourd'hui sont
contents et aussi alors philippe donc on
va se retrouver le 31 janvier ici au
théâtre montansier pour le premier
concert de saint michel à sa fin le
premier concert le signe qu'on est très
heureux de jouer pour la première assez
génial ça y est ici en plus oui parce
que c'est un lieu qui vous également
familier gym a lieu magique magic et
connaissiez déjà vous imaginez pas petit
nom un jour jouer ici sur cette reine
voilà de quoi vous découvrir déjà un
petit point avant première avec un clip
et après vous allez nous emmener dans un
autre lieu
mappy le travail là on bosse tous les
jours qui est qui est une lieu de
résidence musicale qui nous a été
confiée par par la mairie c'est un
endroit génial bon et travailler dans
des supers conditions d'un disons pas
plus et vous allez découvrir et alosi
vous emmène au quai
sinon
tu vois
amour
ce que
bon va fille voilà nous sommes dans un
autre endroit dans votre bain merci on
découvre là votre laboratoire votre
cuisine votre studio d'enregistrement
exactement là on fait même peut-être
tambouille quotidienne voilà vous
travaillez conserver vos morceaux et
vous êtes à résidence en fait absolument
à côté moi comment ça s'est passé
tout ça s'est fait grâce à ioane turbé
de l'offre free qui nous a contactés
et
on a pris un rendez vous on s'est
rencontré il avait à coeur de nous de
pouvoir nous aider un peu à peu
développé en tant qu on voit là en tant
que représentant de la culture
versaillaise corps et du coup il nous a
permis d'obtenir grâce aussi à sophie
dany ce qu'est la conservatrice de la
bibliothèque
oui parce que en fait cet endroit c'est
l'appartement de fonction de la
conservatrice mais ne l'occupant pas
elle a trouvé l'idée chouette gars
l'asie banco que saint michel vient de
s'installer
génial ouais fantastique donc vous avez
à votre disposition un appartement qui a
l'air assez grand absolument et donc on
voit d'ailleurs tous vos instruments
mais là on est dans le salon
du coup l'une des plus grandes pièces
qui nous sert à enregistrer ici à peu
près tous d'accord c'est requis si on
peut aussi bien faire des batteries que
des guitares des synthés et surtout ici
on peut s'installer à plusieurs pour
faire des prises de groupe où on va
travailler éventuellement avec paul ou
avec d'autres musiciens qui pourrait
intervenir d'accord sur les manceaux
voilà ok oui mais c'est comme on l'a
déjà dit vous faites avant tout vous
même deux mois de la composition des
musiques mélodies et les paroles paroles
c'est vous qui écrivez absolument tout
ouais tout seul ouais voilà je vous ai
fait corriger par des des anglais oui
c'est vrai pour être sûr d'être nickel
est alors après vous m'expliquer donc il
ya d'autres pièces dans cet appartement
et vous avec votre formation d'ingénieur
du son vous êtes hyper pointu si je
puisais vous êtes allé repérer
finalement quelle pièce convenait le
mieux
pour quels instruments quels instruments
ouais c'est ça comment comment vous
expliquez ça bah c'est un peu empirique
comme méthode
au départ on fait des tests pour voir
comment sonne la pièce qu'elle a
beaucoup de reverb parce qu'elle a peu
de réserves à ce qu'avait sèche ce cas
les réseaux nantes ancenis quel
caractère est là est ce qu'elle va
favoriser les basses médiums et aigus et
of the way et par rapport à tout ça du
sud ont ensuite on décide du coût de 10
enregistrée tu as lutté l'instrument
hockey m'écouter génial merci nous avoir
dévoilé cette part de votre intimité
musicale mais bon les puits
à très vite à très bientôt on espérait
faire découvrir rapidement le deuxième
album oui on est donc été ici pour le
mans paris pour faire le travail
d'écriture et d'enregistrement des
grives ici aussi
ouais ouais j'ai écrit beaucoup ici
j'écrivais pas la nuit si j'écris aussi
la num ça dépend des périodes mais là
avec un tel endroit c'est génial de
venir y aspirant sortir sa guitare on it
et écrire des choses et vous pensez que
ça va faire si votre musique
c'est ce que je veux mettre de la
musique baroque du coup dans le deuxième
album qui n'était pas prévu dans un
bâtiment d'époque
ouais je pense que c'est un bâtiment
classé on est entouré d'un truc comme
700 mille livres
donc du coup ça donne vachement envie de
de s'ancrer dans l'histoire de la ville
donc le maître du baroque et ça c'est
bon signe vraiment fait d'être ici
à l'abri derrière moi j'ai fait tout le
premier album dans ma chambre de 15
mètres carrés oui c'est donc chez
j'avais chez moins penser au maroc
on vous laisse travailler merci philippe
merci d'avancé
amy sera là ouais sûrement super merci a
bientot merci